لقد حدث الكثير مما أتذكره هنا على
مسافة قريبة من هذا
المنتزه ، تقترح أختي أنني أزور
مدينة ملقة ، لقد هرعت فقط
في الطريق من المطار للوصول إلى
الشاطئ
[موسيقى]
مرة
أخرى جهلي كعابد للشمس
معروضة بالكامل ،
تعد ملقة أكثر بكثير من مجرد رحلة في
المطار أو سيارة أجرة ، فأنا أتعلم أنها
توفر نوعًا من الاستكشاف الذي
يحدث فقط عندما أتباطأ
لتقدير الأجزاء الدقيقة من الحياة
[الموسيقى]
الملقة هي مسقط رأس
الفن الإسباني  هدية إلى العالم بابلو
بيكاسو أعرف في مكان ما على طول رحلاتي ، لقد
سمعت ذلك ولكني لم أفعل أي شيء
حيال ذلك حتى الآن
[موسيقى]
أنا أستمتع بجولة في الساعات الأولى من
متحف بابلو بيكاسو.
مبتذلة
وغامضة بالتأكيد ، لكن عندما أكون في
معرض فني مثل هذا ، أعتقد أن شيئين
أولاً ، ما قيمة كل واحدة من هذه الأشياء
، وثانيًا ، إذا أعطيت الخيار
الذي سأعود إليه للمنزل ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو
تمثال نصفي لرجل  مع قبعة
يمكنني أن أتحدث معك يا سيدي
[الموسيقى]
التي كانت تستحق ذلك
، الشمس الأندلسية
، 11 نغمة
للجرس ، المتحف مفتوح الآن ،
آه ، أشعر بالرضا ويشعر بالرضا حقًا